welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and we just got a new trailer for
the batman story robert pattinson a
movie i've been stoked for ever since
its zodiac inspired first trailer last
year and hey we can rest easy now that
the real life zodiac has been revealed
dead or has he i mean i don't believe it
no police are knocking at my door so
anyway i am going to react to this
trailer with a blind eye give you my
initial thoughts and then tomorrow will
be my frame by frame analysis breaking
down everything that you might miss from
this trailer but let's take a look here
we
go
sad riddler
oh he's letting himself get caught
very um
john doe and seven or uh
joker dark knight hannibal lecter
hope you tip that barista
awesome
cool fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing less
oh
all right save it for the breakdown
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there honestly the
kyle in this one
god i'm vengeance
god damn the action is great
what's black
and blue
and dead
all over
[Music]
i got you
this movie's called penguin
oh
yes
ah yes but real quick orcs get a bad rap
in most fantasy fiction but have you
ever taken the time to really get to
know one start that emotional journey
today by downloading this video's
sponsor raid shadow legends use the
links below to download raid to your
mobile phone or pc in raid champions
from the orc faction are super useful in
helping you progress through the game
iron braggo or crelo witch arm can help
you blast your way through dungeons or
the clan boss they also look incredible
one of the most fun parts of the game is
exploring the factions of champions
within the game and the different
strengths they can bring to your team
pair up orcs with some dwarves or maybe
the hound spawn hello houndspawn you're
like a dog but demonic fun raid's got a
busy schedule of events and activities
including an absolutely jam-packed
halloween lineup this month big rewards
tournaments against other players and
special fragment events to get some
brand new legendary champions including
one very creepy halloween champion raid
is bigger busier and better than ever
and there are some giant updates coming
very soon so there's really never been a
better time to get started if you want
to get a huge head start in raid all you
have to do is hit the link in the
description or scan our qr code and
you'll get an epic hero chonoru who's
amazing in the doom tower as well as two
hundred thousand silver one xp boost one
energy refill and one ancient shard so
you can summon an awesome champion as
soon as you get in game all of this
treasure will be waiting for you right
here and once you're in you can find me
in game under the name
newrock2020 and if you're fast you can
join my clan and it's that easy just
click the link in the description and
i'll see you in the game wow so this is
already shaping up to be one of the most
hard-hitting brutal batman films we've
ever seen by once again using nirvana as
something in the way matt reeves really
is evoking some of those david fincher
detective noir elements this is truly
going to be a detective story and one of
my favorite twists is the fact that it
looks like edward nashton the riddler
allows himself to get arrested pretty
early in the story or at least halfway
through it and that he's largely going
to be a threat behind bars as many of
the best villains in cinema are whether
they're hannibal lecter or heath
ledger's the joker in the dark knight
just because they're incarcerated
doesn't mean they're any less dangerous
and it seems like the riddler is going
to have a series of clues and further
riddles that come out even after he's
been detained that he set up this
tightly wound machine to continue to
perpetuate itself and that him being
arrested is part of his plan reminds me
a lot of batman hush how riddler is a
seemingly inactive character but is
actually behind of a lot of what is
going on now matt reeves never cited
hutch he actually said year one in the
interview before this trailer dropped a
lot of people have been pointing out the
similarities to uh the long halloween in
the past matt reeves has mentioned
darwin cook's ego but in general this
looks like a story that's less about
making overt references to the comic
books and having easter eggs in there
and just using some of those thematic
elements to just tell a good detective
story which is something that i've been
craving for batman he's the world's
greatest detective we should see his
investigative sleuthing before we see
anything else i mean not that you would
know it from this trailer because he
spent like 90 of it beating the crap out
of everyone he can find now there's this
one overhead shot that looks either like
riddles that the riddler left behind or
more likely something that bruce wayne
started to sketch out as he's trying to
dig into edward nashton's mind i'll dig
more into this in the trailer breakdown
for sure but already we see the names
mitchell and coulson mitchell being the
mayor don mitchell who was the murder
victim from the first trailer coulson
being peter sarsgaard gil coulson the
d.a he's the one who's forced into
driving the suv into the funeral we also
see the name savage confirming my theory
that commissioner peter savage was going
to be the next target and of course the
sins of my father i think one of the big
reveals from this movie is that the
wayne family is part of the corruption
of gotham city i've speculated that the
court of owls could factor into this
plot and we know from the court of owl's
storyline that alan wayne bruce's
grandfather designed a lot of the
buildings in gotham leaving those 13th
floors empty for the court of houzz
executioner talon to use as kind of a
base of operations to jump around from
building a building and track people
down now this trailer shows us a lot
more of zoe kravitz's selena kyle she's
not yet catwoman this is really kind of
an origin story of the character and it
sounds like they're introducing just a
new version of the character as opposed
to one who's tied to any specific batman
comic story line she's a cat burglar
with short hair but there's also a shot
where it looks like she's in a nightclub
with a wig she may like work in that
nightclub and maybe like a friend of
hers got killed and maybe she's like
avenging a friend of hers there's a bit
more of colin farrell as oz cobblepot
not yet the penguin and the past matt
reeves has said he actually bristles and
gets pissed off when anyone calls him
the penguin again completely
unrecognizable under this facial makeup
but again i doubt he'll be the final
villain of this story he seems like just
kind of a organized crime boss kind of
like what falcone was in the christopher
nolan movies actually by the way we
haven't seen him yet but john tuturo is
playing carmine falcone in this movie
and i have speculated in the past that
the falconies may have been in bed with
the mayor don mitchell jr helped him get
elected because on his wall in his
office there was a newspaper clipping
saying oh big maroney crime bust so the
mayor might have taken down the
falcone's rivals and maroneys and the
falcones ended up being in the mayor's
pocket i mean it all comes back to what
edward nashton's end game is what does
he want from all this well his targets
are the mayor the d.a the police
commissioner he seems to be taking down
the major city leaders these are
political assassinations which means he
probably hates the city of gotham he
hates its leadership structure there's
something in the way they'd been running
this city that he used to be corrupt and
i think bruce wayne and his family have
played a role in that corruption anyway
there is so much in this trailer that i
need to spend more time with to break
down the visuals the sound effects the
music the fight choreography i'm gonna
need some more time to dig into that so
be patient my frame by frame trailer
analysis is gonna come out on the
channel tomorrow you can support new
rockstars in the meantime by checking
out our merch options
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you